sí bueno sin duda un reto ante el
coronavirus realizarlo de manera digital
hay opiniones mixtas al respecto pero
bueno el partido republicano también va
a tener este reto de no tener una
comisión tradicional no creo que de lo
más relevante fue como se quiso mostrar
las diferencias o las presuntas
diferencias entre bailén como un hombre
abierto al bipartidismo que logra reunir
personas de izquierda pero también de
centro y buscando incluso a republicanos
que estén molestos o que no les guste el
actual gobierno creo que se resaltó
mucho este punto y también el hecho de
que se le dio muchísima importancia a la
diversidad del país no vimos voces de
afroamericanos y de mujeres en el centro
de la convención creo que también
resaltando la la creciente diversidad
en eeuu bueno pero vimos también que
bailén instó a la unidad al pueblo
estadounidense para superar lo que llamó
una época oscura del país logrará esta
unidad entonces bardem y ese resultado
podría verse en las urnas
bueno sin duda lo que están buscando y
realmente al ver voces como michael
bloomberg como decían como john cage y
ser su gobernador republicano es un poco
lo que está intentando la campaña no va
a traer personas muy diferentes para
lograr la mayoría de las elecciones y
luego intentar tener un gobierno un poco
más de unidad no obviamente el país está
muy polarizado e incluso si yo voy a
llegar a ganar con una elección muy
amplia va a ser muy difícil tener tanta
tanta unidad en el congreso como en el
partido republicano pero de cara a las
elecciones creo que si está buscando
esto tener realmente una alianza muy
diversa en su voto de sus votantes y
bueno creo que es lo que realmente
subrayaron en esta convención de estar
abierto a todas las tendencias que hay
en el país bueno y para finalizar
cuéntenos ahora que bardem es candidato
oficial que se puede esperar de la
convención republicana la próxima semana
bueno creo que vamos a ver un contraste
en el en el discurso obviamente bailén
hablaba más de esperanza de cambio de lo
que puede ser el próximo año mientras
que tron pues seguramente intentará
resaltar lo más positivo de estos cuatro
años no y exista sobre todo la cierta
mejoría económica que ha habido luego de
obviamente el bajón importante por el
coronavirus no intentar sacar alguno de
esos datos más positivos y también creo
que buscarán generar mucho miedo de lo
que puede hacer un gobierno de va a ir
borrando intentando borrar esta imagen
de alguien conciliador y más bien
presentándolo como alguien muy de de la
extrema izquierda no creo que son dos de
las cosas que veremos en la convención
republicana que creo que a diferencia de
la demócrata si tendrá algunos eventos
con más público no no no será
enteramente digital como la demócrata
pero igual estarán muy limitados por la
pandemia que que estamos sufriendo